hello
my name is nicholas and welcome to the
wolfram tech conference
i'm a math content developer with the
wolframa math group and a phd candidate
finishing up at indiana university
wherein my research focuses on
graph-based percolation theory
in the wolfram language with application
to the collapse of viruses
so among the other 12 talks i'm sure
you're attending today
we'll be discussing percolation theory
with applications to the collapse of
viruses
so i will gloss over the abstract give
you a chance to pause if you're watching
the
video in the web deployment later and
read it if you so choose and i'll take
the opportunity to
thank my current collaborator professor
ryden tuarek at the university of york
for ongoing mentorship and collaboration
and past experimental collaborators in
the zlotnik lab at iu for
experimentally validating a few of the
predictions i'll present today
so an overview of percolation theory
it's
a mathematical approach to modeling a
variety of phenomena
that involve connectivity of agents in a
given system
so it's used to model say fluid flow
through
random porous media and a large swath of
phenomena modeled with network theory
such as
assessing the robustness to random or
targeted attack or failure
in say an electrical grid or a traffic
flow network
etc we'll go through a few of these
sequentially
on the left you have a two-dimensional
cubic lattice wherein
50 of the sites are occupied or blocked
those are the black cells
and 50 are unoccupied the y cells
if you were attempting to as a fluid
flow from the left side to the right
side of the system
you would be able to because of the
third row
being entirely white cells there's the
opportunity to percolate from the left
to the right side
however you can imagine as we
observe different random instantiations
of some fractional occupancy of a
lattice like this
if we increase the fraction of occupied
black cells from 50 percent to say 70
percent
there's a high probability that one of
those additional
occupied cells will land in that third
row
such that it forms a blockade or a
blockage
and fluid is no longer able to percolate
through that system
the study of connectivity as a function
of
random occupation fraction or deletion
fraction
as the inverse is the study of
percolation theory
and it depends upon the topology of this
lattice is it a cubic lattice
is it a hexagonal lattice etc
you'll see a 3d equivalent of that in
the center where we have a 3d cubic
lattice
wherein you'd study percolation from say
left to right top to bottom etc
again studying the connectivity from
side to side or the connectivity of the
entire lattice depending on your
application
in particular you'll notice in the 3d
equivalent here
that there is a vertex at the center of
each lattice site
this vertex represents the lattice side
itself
whereas the edges between the vertices
represent connectivity of the lattice
sites
so the two formalisms to describe
percolation theory numerically
are lattices and by graph lattice
duality
graphs or networks so stripping away the
lattice formalism because the wolfram
language is
contains rather
graph theory functionality we'll use the
graph theory formalism
where in an example with that if we
generate a random graph here and take
that to be representative of
say an electrical grid there's a central
hub
in the electrical grid and then a couple
individuals that
like you always have are off grid insist
on that at times
and then some individuals who are
perhaps in a rural area
where they're connected but only weekly
so to the central hub
notice for those individuals in
particular if
say the upper right most leaf here where
there are three individuals that are
weakly connected to the hub by an
intermediary who's in the center
if that intermediary were to fail or
become disconnected
the other three individuals in that
right uppermost leaf
would also become disconnected this
investigation of the connectivity within
a network and its robustness to say
random failures of components
or targeted attack of components by some
adversarial entity for example
is an important consideration in the
design of
these engineered networks so it's
important to know that
if one component fails a large a whole
street is not going to lose power for
example
so we will look at percolation theory
with application to
a less common system which is in
physical virology
the disassembly of viral shells
so a virus's shell which is shown on the
left for i believe hepatitis b virus the
source is below
this is a protein surface representation
of
the regularly tiled shell that protects
viruses while they're in transit between
hosts so if someone
coughs the virus is going to spend some
amount of time
outside of anyone's body in sub-optimal
conditions
and its genome is very fragile it's
enzymes and other transcription uh
machinery
is very fragile and it needs to be kept
together as the cargo of this shell
and needs to be protected by the
exterior of the shell
and so these things can survive often
for
a week or more on a given surface
because of the protection of this viral
shell that encloses them
and we'll study the physics of this
virus shell or the topology of this
virus shell
so these virus shells form very regular
lattices
made out of repeating individual
components called subunits
so you can see that the spike tips
emerging from in the leftmost figure
the red spike tips emerging from the
surface are in a fairly regular array
there are a lot of hexagonal patterns
here and
the array is very regular it's not just
a random
amalgamation of legos for example it's a
very regular
system of repeating tiles
if we move to the right to the center
the
protein surface has been made
transparent
and the underlying polygonal structure
the rhombic tiling is is outlined
along with its dual graph if we then
strip from that the protein
representation and stick with the
abstract polyhedral
representation on the right you can see
very clearly this is a highly regular
tiled lattice and it is amazing an
amazing feat of
biology that these subunits when they're
made
in mass quantities individually in the
cell upon infection
are able to spontaneously assemble into
one of these blueprints and it follows
one of these blueprints precisely
and so a viral capsule is a regular
tiling
of for about half of species a sphere
with repeated subunits in a specific
geometric arrangement
and this can be represented by either
the polyhedral tiling
the lattice or the
dual graph by graph lattice duality
wherein subunits are represented by a
vertex
and the bonds holding the subunits
together
are represented by edges
so we'll study the disassembly of these
viruses because both assembly
as i mentioned and disassembly of
viruses is key to the viral life cycle
and a simple and experimentally realized
model of
disassembly is just the random removal
of subunits
so in the same way we had random
fractional occupancy or random
fractional deletion
in the cubic lattice in the initial
example in this
spherical lattice we have random
occupancy or random
subunit removal for disassembly of virus
shells
this specifically is continuing our
hepatitis b virus example
and you can see predictions that we've
made using these models that i'll
highlight more clearly in a moment
in the uppermost reference here the
theory reference
where we made certain predictions and in
an experimental paper where
the this specific random subunit
dissociation
model was realized and the predictions
were experimentally verified
so we'll go through those a little bit
more systematically after a mathematical
generalization
so the disassembly of viruses consists
of removing
some fraction of its subunits and
studying the product
that remains so as physicists and
mathematicians we seek to generalize
things the previous examples have been
with hepatitis b virus
that was in the previous paper i have a
collaborator
ryden twarak at the university of york
who has
deduced that there are archimedean
design principles
that dictate that there are exactly
three types of lattices that may be
constructed out of a single type of
subunit
these lattices are exemplified in
species such as periocotovirus which has
a triangular tiling a
on the left tobacco ring virus which has
a
kite tiling b in the middle and
bacteriophage ms2 and hepatitis b virus
which has aromatic tiling
exemplified in c on the right
and the topology of these networks for
example the subunit valency
the number of bonds connected to
each subunit
the arrangement of subunits in the
larger lattice beyond local connectivity
the topology of these subunit bond
networks determines their robustness
against fragmentation
so how many pieces can i remove before
this thing falls apart
that is determined by the topology of
the lattice in part
you'll notice that and we'll come back
to this
the triangular tiling on the left the
rhombic tiling on the right are both
fundamentally consistent of triangular
components
the rhombic tiling is essentially each
rhombus is two triangles
triangle tiling clearly each seven is
one triangle we'll come back to the
ability
of these lattices to be further
triangulated
such that they can scale in size by
adding more and more pieces but still
adhering to the
overall triangular or rhombic trend in a
moment
so the topology of this lattice
determines the
propensity for fragmentation and the
robustness against fragmentation
so if we want to determine for any one
of these tilings or all of these
stylings
the fragmentation characteristics
one of the most telling metrics in this
case and the one that is experimentally
detectable
is the fragmentation threshold
this fragmentation threshold is the
fraction of vertices that
when removed induces fragmentation of
the remaining
structure and so
the subunits
are randomly moved at some fraction on
the x-axis in this plot
the connection probability on the y-axis
is determined through monte carlo
and the point at which these
connection probabilities for each
lattice transcend
0.5 is the point at which on average the
system has gone from breaking up into
two or fewer compute components to two
or more components
so this is the point at which the system
is on average fragmented
and so i'll go through the technique
briefly since the wolfram language talk
of using vertex delete with a graph
representation of the lattice as we
highlighted
wherein you use a table function to
iterate over the x-axis variable
using vertex delete operating on the
graph of
your choice here and because you need to
monte carlo this for each point say you
run 100 000
a million 10 million replicates the
automatic parallelism within mathematica
the wolfram language excuse me is
capable of
expeditiously generating the millions of
points you need to do monte carlo here
so lag
so we'll notice that we've predicted
the fragmentation threshold for each of
the three
systems here triangular which is the
weakest
rhombic which is the central and kite
which is the most robust
you notice that triangular had a valency
or a vertex degree
of three you might anticipate this would
lead to
and maybe even be the dominant factor in
determining whether or not the system is
robust to disassembly
just simply the number of bonds holding
the system together
and indeed the triangular tiling is the
weakest
however the distance between in terms of
the difference between their
uh fragmentation thresholds the
difference between rhombic tilings
which have a valency of four and
triangular tilings which have a valency
of three
is about the same as the distance
between rhombic tilings with a
valency of four and kite tilings with a
valency of four
so the contribution just a qualitative
guess from this plot the contribution
from
topology beyond simple local valency
is pretty significant because if it
weren't the
propensity for disassembly of the
rhombic tiling and the kite tiling
would be comparable so for each of these
three viral blueprints we've determined
the
fragmentation threshold and each species
of virus has to
utilize if it has only one single type
of subunit
one of these three viral archetypes
however
it's a little bit more complicated than
that there aren't just three cases there
are three
archetypes two of which can be extended
in size as we discussed
so the triangular tiling as illustrated
here from the left to the right
a triangular tiling can be further
triangulated this is why for example you
have the triforce in zelda
it's four triangles composing one larger
triangle
this ability to further triangulate a
spherical surface
lends itself to size scalability
in the number of subunits and often in
the physical size
of a given shell despite having
very small individual subunits so if a
viral species finds itself with
a very large genome over the course of
evolution
it will need a larger
viral shell to protect it to contain it
than a species that has a smaller genome
however there are only three archetypes
you can choose from and so it needs to
choose one of the archetypes
that can be scaled in size rip readily
such that it can contain its genome and
protect it in transit between hosts
this scalability and size is allowable
in two of the three archetypes
triangular tilings and rhombic tilings
the fragmentation threshold depends
predominantly upon the topology of the
individual
blueprint however it also depends on the
size of the lattice in question such
that one triangular tiling on the left
for example
will have a higher fragmentation
threshold than a tiling on say the right
before we move on to illustrate this
more quantitatively
i want to highlight how easy it is to
make these polyhedra in the wolfram
language
wherein you can just generate one of
these triangular tilings by using the
nth order geodesian
of fundamental graphics primitives
polyhedral primitives
such as an icosahedron or a dodecahedron
wherein the leftmost figure here was
generated as the second-order
geodesicion of the icosahedron
you can then use some functionality that
i believe is becoming more and more
native to the
kernel in order to generate from this
polyhedral representation a
graph i ended up writing those myself
because it's not terribly challenging
but i i think that in version 12 some of
this functionality became native
to generate the 3d graph that you need
to actually do this percolation stuff
from the polyhedral
representation so there's a size
dependence of the fragmentation
threshold for any one of the three
categories
rather two of them that are capable of
being scaled in size
to represent this more quantitatively
we have a slew of predictions for
experiments only
a small fraction which have been
experimentally validated so far
these two
all of the data that we've collected on
fragmentation thresholds for those three
archetypes capably being made at a
single type of subunit
is presented here on the left for
subunit fragmentation thresholds
wherein each point
is the fragmentation threshold for that
on the x-axis triangulation number
which is a scaling of how many subunits
make up that
make up the capsid so a triangular
lattice with say
t value of 3 which is what we've been
studying so far in this talk
has fewer subunits than one with a
triangulation number of say t equals 36
and for the two archetypes that are
capable of being scaled in size
this fragmentation decreases
from the baseline values set by the
topology of the blueprint
and this size dependence is from in part
a propensity to
exclude singlets an increasing
propensity to exclude cinglets as
the size of the system is scaled upwards
similarly something we haven't discussed
bond percolation is also heavily
investigated in these systems wherein
instead of randomly removing subunits
you randomly remove some fraction of the
bonds holding the subunits together and
then investigate the propensity for the
system to fragment
and so you can determine in the same way
we were determining in the left plot
the fraction of subunits that leads to
on average fragmentation
you can compute the fraction of bonds
whose removal
on average leads to fragmentation and it
has fairly similar behaviors even the
magnitudes of the number are fairly
similar
however in the leftmost system at least
one of the points
has been experimentally detected so the
fragmentation threshold of hepatitis b
virus has been detected experimentally
in one of our collaborator a paper with
a collaborator
that was cited earlier however none of
the other fra
fragmentation thresholds subunit
fragmentation thresholds or bond
thresholds have been detected yet
the success of the modeling technique
for hepatitis b viruses subunit
fragmentation threshold
would lend one to think that this is a
great opportunity for experimentalists
to detect the other points on these
graphs the other fragmentation
thresholds subunit and bond
that exist so if you're an
experimentalist and you happen to work
on
other systems other species of virus and
it realizes one of these other single
subunit blueprints
at a given size you may be able to
design an experiment
to see if fragmentation occurs when a
given fraction of the subunits or bonds
are
deleted
so the fragmentation threshold is not
the entire story
if you have dedicated and precise
say single particle technique detection
experimentation equipment you can detect
fragment size distributions
theoretically
such that you can show that
the in say the top left case which these
are organized with respect to on the top
subunit fragmentation products and
bond fragmentation products and the way
we were discussing on the previous slide
and then a b and c are the three
different archetypes and then d
and f are the bond equivalents for the
three different archetypes
so if we take the exemplary case in the
top left
the blue distribution is where you've
removed only 10 percent of the subunits
from the shell
which is well below the fragmentation
threshold such that the system is
largely still
unfragmented and therefore you get
for the most part a binomial
distribution of products
where if on average you were missing 10
percent
there will be at times with any random
algorithm
a time where you're missing say hundred
and uh twelve percent
versus eight percent or fourteen percent
and six percent such that it averages
out to
10 with a binomial distribution the
spinal distribution decreases
at the peak due to the increasing
propensity for fragmentation by the time
you move to the pink distribution at 20
percent
and you can see that it's spread out the
cdf shown as the line
is more spread out to represent the
peak distribution yet it's still
predominantly a binomial distribution
because we're
a few percent below the fragmentation
threshold however if you increase
10 percent further to what should be the
green distribution here
you don't see a green distribution
binomially because it's we're at 30
percent
removal and the fragmentation threshold
was i believe about 21 22 percent
for this system triangular lattice
so instead of seeing any binomial
distribution here because of
fragmentation
you see no intermediate sizes at all
you just see a bunch of
fragmented products at size of 10
subunits or fewer
so this is a hallmark of percolation
theory generally that as you approach
the either the fragmentation threshold
or
the less rigid percolation threshold
you rapidly go from having a connected
hole
to nothing but a slew of small
disconnected fragments
there's not often a situation where if
you have a 60 subunit
structure you remove 30 pieces
you'll have two size 15 structures left
where you have a 67-inch structure you
remove 20 pieces
you'll have two 20-piece structures left
the probability of that is very low but
due to the random removal
and you instead have a slew of smaller
products and so you anticipate
experimentally as you're
titrating in so to speak in the number
of
deleted subunits the stoichiometry of
the passivated subunits in the previous
experiment i was referencing
as you're titrating in the fraction of
subunits removed you're going to rapidly
lose signal for anything
of significant size as you approach this
fragmentation threshold
these distributions i've shown here are
likely to be skewed by other effects
we're only considering topology here
we're not considering thermodynamics
and we're not considering time
dependence the gradual breakup
of these things if they're weakly bound
however even for weakly bound systems
in the hepatitis b virus case where
contacts are simply hydrophobic instead
of covalent
even in the weakly bound case we observe
fairly precisely
the predicted topological fragmentation
threshold such that these effects are
not expected to
nullify the results the predictions made
here
so in conclusion you can predict in a
molecular game of
jenga if you're familiar with the north
american board game
the percolation theory
fragmentation threshold of
virus capsids depending on the viral
blueprint that is employed
there are a fairly finite number of
viral blueprints that viruses can
use due to mathematical constraints we
have predicted the fragmentation
threshold for
each of the viruses blueprints
that are capable of being made out of a
single type of subunit
so this is an opportunity for
experimentalists to go out and detect
all of the non-hepatitis b virus
thresholds
and the bond threshold of hepatitis b
virus
i'll take a moment to highlight the
simplicity of this modeling technique
relative to the other modeling
techniques used in the field
the established modeling techniques used
in physical virology
tend to be reaction kinetics which are
time dependent differential equations
with a very coarse grained
representation of thermodynamics
essentially one or a few parameters a
delta g constant for example
these systems are fairly simple
however they do require time dependence
consideration of kinetics
and thermodynamic considerations more
complicated systems still
with more explicit representation of
these phenomena are molecular dynamics
simulations
wherein you have implicit time
dependence by virtue of running the
simulation
represented by the propagation of
explicit
energies specified between entities in
the simulation
and thermodynamics in the given ensemble
that you're working in
these systems are both fairly
complicated
in that they have time dependence they
have thermodynamic dependence have
energetics dependence
that is ignored in the percolation
theory model
percolation theory is a vastly simpler
topological only
model which is still capable of making
robust predictions
and because of this simplicity
you can do this entirely in the wolfram
language expeditiously due to
parallelism
of the system so you can use a graph
theory formalism to model percolation of
lattices or graph
systems and do so expeditiously because
of the automatic parallelism in the
wolfram language
i'm happy to answer any questions if
you'd like to
ask a quick question after the talk i've
probably gone over a little bit on time
such that we can also schedule a
breakout meeting if you prefer
or you can email me at my email and
bronc wolfram.com
thank you so can you guys hear me
you sound good okay so uh dave asked
excuse me dave asked if uh virus
capsules tend to fail
without fragmentation by simply opening
and leaking
it depends on what the size of the
molecules in question are
so if you consider the protein diagram
of the
protein representation of the virus
shell those are naturally
some species are naturally porous to
small molecules
such that say like drugs ligands etc
small molecules can go in and out of the
virus shell
generally larger stuff like the stuff
the virus cares about
containing for example the genome etc
take up the majority of the space in the
virus shell
and uh it's not poorest to those and uh
i'm primarily a physicist not a
biologist so i won't pretend to have
you know as much expertise as my
experimental collaborators or as my
collaborator at the university of york
but my understanding of
these virus shells is that a lot of them
have
specific engineering to prevent opening
and leaking at the wrong time
like some of them have uh portal
proteins
and some of them have molecular motors
that are designed to through these
portals
uh actively put work in
to pump the genome in or release the
genome
such that uh you don't have to have
porosity or active disassembly
as we studied in this talk in order to
release the genome or encapsulate the
genome
these viruses will uh in terms of
general failure
they're remarkably robust like uh
depending on the species i
think and you know i haven't done
research on this covid is uh
you know it will survive on a surface
for several days at least is
my understanding of what i've read uh
just in popular science stuff
uh there i have heard of experiments
with other virus species where these
things will remain stable
on this on uh in a test tube for example
for weeks or months
uh often not even exchanging subunits
with the environment transiently
so i hope that goes at least you know
a quarter of the way towards answering
your question to some extent uh
it depends a lot on the virus species
how porous it is how prone to failure it
is in what time frame
whether or not that failure is random
soviet removal or targeted removal
etc biology is amazingly complicated and
uh i can't speak to it much more than
the general assessment i've given here
are there any other questions
in the event there aren't questions i do
have uh an example like a do-it-yourself
kind of example that i've cooked up
uh i'll upload let me share my screen
here
also interrupt me if you have a targeted
question
oh okay uh how do i
unmute someone let me unshare my screen
so that we can discuss your question
if you have a question uh click the
raise hand button
and then we can promote you so you can
talk yeah just like that
okay so have we have we enabled him
so
i didn't know you had to unmute
um very nice talk nick uh very
thoughtful and
very uh well presented congratulations
thank you um i i'm intrigued
and i can't elaborate anymore on on the
stuff inside the shell but if you
imagine
the uh the subunits
as wiggling around or moving and only
being rigid when
they are connected to enough additional
subunits next to them
then you might imagine that if a subunit
was
connected to only one other subunit
it might wiggle more so to speak
um eventually a long string of sub units
wouldn't probably maintain a spherical
geometry it would probably unfold a
little bit if you wish
does that make sense yeah yeah one one
of the really amazing things about these
uh virus shells is that yeah all of the
entropic effects
the thermodynamic effects are all
counteracting
the precise self-assembly into a uniform
shell
and so i've heard other people you know
i can't claim credit for this analogy
but assembling these shells in the first
place without an active
you know active a person actually
assembling them
is an amazing feat similar to if you
just threw up a
handful of cards a deck of cards and it
fell and assembled a house
of cards uh the
extent which has to counteract those
entropic effects is pretty amazing
and uh i have a colleague whose entire
phd project
is to uh model the molecular dynamics of
the assembly of those pieces such that
if you have a box where a bunch of the
pieces are coming together
they will gradually form at first say a
planar structure like you were
describing
and then gradually it start to induce a
radius of curvature and then close the
shell
and uh one of the main challenges in her
work has been to counteract those
entropic forces you're describing
where uh you know it's difficult to get
the bond geometry
correct the interfacial geometry between
the subunits correct such that it wants
to form a sphere instead of say just a
glob
right and uh so yeah that's absolutely a
valid uh
point electrodynamics simulation people
struggle with that
and uh it's very amazing that nature has
figured out how to assemble these things
within a matter of seconds
uh into the precise lattice that they
that it assembles
another thought um would would have to
do with
say a planar model um
you have subunits like hexagons that
that form
larger groups or islands of hexagons
if if hexagons like to be near other
hexagons then just like
small droplets of oil would coalesce
into larger
droplets of oil if sitting on a water
surface i that's kind of my mental model
for how this self-assembly of
viral subunits or protein subunits of
any type
occurs so that if you delete one
and then delete another one elsewhere
it seems to me that one of those
subunits might just sort of
shift itself to fill in one of the holes
and leave the other
a double hole if that makes sense
right so uh that's a very good way of
picturing uh
this generally hydrophobic forces are
what leads to
aggregation of oil so that it wants to
minimize the interfacial surface area
and in the same way there are
hydrophobic surfaces on the subunit
edges that when these things come
together
the hydrophobic surfaces bury one
another and hide one another from the
solvent
such that you don't have that energy
penalty of solvent exposed hydrophobic
surfaces between the subunits
and so uh that's a very good way of
thinking about it and uh
generally self-assembly is driven by uh
subunit subunit bonds that are on the
order of about four kbt
of energy such that uh if one kbt is the
standing thermal free energy the
extent to which stuff is jiggling it
needs about a bond of
bond strength of 4 kbt to hold it
together to counteract the jiggling away
from each other
uh the reason that that is effective
beyond
simply say four-fold is because these
things are say trivalent or tetravalent
so that if they're trivalent and they're
4kbt of energy per bond
and this thing taking the my hand to be
the subunit this thing has a bond here
bond here bond here and then bond here
for a tetravalent
subunit then as these things come
together in a lattice they have
in that case 16 kbt of energy and that's
a considerable
uh thermodynamic barrier to dissociation
or even rearrangement
such that if you had say a lattice tiled
like this and you removed one piece
from say the center here and then the
other one had a surrounding three pieces
it still has 12 kbt
of energy holding it in place and so
that prohibits rearrangement to some
extent
and then uh in the experimental setup we
had
uh in one of the papers i highlighted
there there were actually covalent bonds
each of which are more on the order of
50 kbt of energy in which case you have
150 kbt
holding those things in place and so
these things are surprisingly rigid
uh experiments have been done with i
think hepatitis b virus but i wouldn't
quote me on that
showing that uh if you have a fully
assembled shell and it sits in a test
tube
these things will uh not even exchange
so like a subunit won't fall out and
another one joins in
for months you know the the the ability
of 16
20 24 or 150 kbt of energy holding the
subunits in place essentially
counteracts even transient exchange of
subunits let alone the rearrangement or
falling apart of the whole thing
and uh yeah so they're amazingly robust
for you know just soft little proteins
and it actually makes you wonder how
they can ever fall apart
right yeah yeah it's uh i think you can
probably do
simple like thermo-organic estimates of
the time scale of dissociation you know
i know for like glass forming glass
formation and glass movement
in like a windowpane or something it's
like 10 to the 8th you know days or
something like that
uh it's probably not that high for these
things but yeah it's amazingly
high given the energetic barrier of
anything from that
16 to 150 or 200 kbt of energy
it's amazingly high given that it's an
exponential dependence
so if the virus has to deliver its
payload
how does it ever manage to dissociate to
do that
there are a lot of different uh so this
is like the random subunit removal is
like the simplest model of that
there some species employ targeted
removal in which case this model
wouldn't apply to those species at least
in so far as the biological uh
disassembly goes
where they remove say if there's
pentagonal components to lattice and
hexagonal components the pentagonal
components
will actively rearrange upon some
confirmation change in the subunit
that's triggered by
a certain event in the viral life cycle
uh so biology has figured out
engineering tricks
where it will do a conformational switch
or something such that targeted removal
occurs
in which case this model isn't
applicable to that and uh
uh there there's a variety of different
approaches that
biology will figure out in some cases
they use motor proteins to actually
remove the
uh genome itself without ever actually
dissociating the capsid at all
and so there are certainly species to
which this doesn't apply uh
biologically uh however with
nanotechnology where you can actually
engineer the system to do certain things
like random subunit removal
like in the experiments we were
highlighting this is more applicable and
uh
yeah the the number of tricks biology
has figured out and
the biologists have figured out that
biology has engineered
are amazing and uh i can't speak to it
as much as i would like uh
but i'm happy to i think we're gonna get
kicked out of here in like one minute i
think pathwill has a
cut off so if you would like to me nick
thank you again it was a neat talk i
liked it
thank you all right well thank you
everyone
i hope you enjoy the tail end of the
tech conference
you